being a human rights activist in China
takes grit take the case of Yu wen Sheng
who was arrested on trumped-up charges
of subverting state power we don't even
know where he's been detained so of
course the focus is on you to the point
though that it's easy sometimes to
forget the family members and the mental
and emotional trauma they endure Xu Yan
is on a mission criss-crossing China on
trains confronting a system shrouded in
secrecy I still don't know where my
husband is or his situation in pursuit
of justice and answers for 680 days her
husband Yuwen Shang a human rights
lawyer has been behind bars where
exactly and for how long
only those in power know I feel helpless
very disappointed and feeling like
there's nothing I can do I also feel
disappointed as they don't do things
according to the law but as I say these
things in my heart I will never give up
I will continue for months she's been
making the long trip to Xu Zhu City
Detention Center where she believes her
husband is being held inside she clings
to hope and a bag of warm clothes for
the long winter ahead in the end there
is no confirmation you is even here the
UN Cheng I know is a good lawyer
he was only practicing his rights and
using his freedom of speech this
shouldn't happen to him and it's very
unfair on my family
flanked by used lawyers she heads next
to the district court to demand
information use case was heard here in
secret please hear though give short
shrift to her desperate plight patience
is running thin my body is extremely
tired going from Beijing to shoe show is
very far
often I leave Beijing in the morning at
5 a.m. and it's not even light at five
sometimes it's raining sometimes it's
snowing it's already been two years I'm
extremely tired tired to the point where
I get sick eventually they resolve to
file a complaint about used treatment
the little expectation that it will make
a difference another day in a calf caius
system seemingly designed to obfuscate
and frustrate joining us is DWS Phoebe
Kong from our East Asia Bureau Phoebe
the UN Sheng case is not an isolated
incident this has been going on for
years we're not only the activists but
the activists family members are
targeted No yeah we can tell this is
just the tip of the iceberg like in
recent years like you have mentioned
activists and human rights lawyer are
often targeted by the authorities they
are well they're prosecuted charged or
even sent to jail but their families are
also the target of the government's that
especially for those who have apparently
committed no crime the fortress the
authorities tried to pressure them by
other means beyond the law for example
Lucia the widow of the Chinese Nobel
Peace Prize laureate Lucia Paul was
under house arrest for 8 years so she
wasn't allowed to leave her own
apartment even though she has never been
charged and offer another example
children is no exception as well that
Chen Guangcheng's
another activist daughter was not
allowed to go to school because of her
father's charge
Phoebe can you tell us a little bit
about how the Chinese justice system
works I understand the activists don't
even have access to their lawyers that
much
yeah in China whenever a sax player is
involved in a weather charge or related
to national security corruption and
terrorism then the authority would
detain them and not letting them to meet
a lawyers not to mention their families
so on they are deprived of their civil
rights to appoint their own legal
representative some of them are even
sent to a secret trial or a sentence
without informing their families CB Cong
thank you